[Music]
guru corner hey guru Singh what's up my
friend Oh make I love this because this
gives us an opportunity this is not an
interview this is a conversation yes and
that's what I love about it because I
don't consider myself to be any more of
an authority than you are and I want to
hear as much about what you're saying as
you want to hear about what I'm saying
and it makes this incredible this
incredible synchronicity well I want to
hear what you have to say I know
everybody else out there does well well
well I want to hear what you have to say
so welcome to another edition of guru
Corner are very popular periodic special
edition of the podcast where I get to
delve deep with this beautiful
incarnation of humanity right here what
did we talk about today we talked about
something very very special we talked
about parenting and how there's no such
thing as the expert parent but there's a
there is a parenting talent mm-hmm that
needs to be developed by both the parent
and the you used this word the
sovereignty of the child yeah super
important
so yeah strategies for parenting all
manner of spiritual perspectives on not
just parenting but humanity living a
conscious life always pleasure my friend
blessings so here it is enjoy this
episode of guru corner with all right
well we're back we're back for another
guru corner yeah I feel like I just
talked to you and you're wearing the
same thing yeah well you know you know
one time somebody said how do you choose
what to wear and I said that's a joke
right
but you do that you have some variety
yeah I go either I go either with blues
or oranges or moon
on top of white yeah and you got it
dialed in my friend why cuz you know how
to rock it you're looking good so as we
were as we were talking before coming on
to the desk here one of your technicians
said that Yogi Bhajan considered hit me
his favorite musician yeah I had never
ever heard that in my entire life oh
come on died he wasn't one to be you
know describing someone as his favorite
you know because that was a little too
narrow but hey if he told somebody that
I was I'll take it yeah so that you like
how that landed I do I mean how many
were there a lot of musicians around him
oh yeah I mean you were rocking it back
then so for sure I mean I'm surprised
that you're surprised by that well only
in that you know the idea of they say in
spirituality you should be eagle less
and ego free and I completely disregard
that I think that if you if you polish
and cut your ego to be brilliant you
should use it and so when I hear those
things that just it just helps me polish
and cut my ego yeah well we all like to
hear nice things about ourselves and the
world from especially from people that
we respect yeah like those most intimate
with us you know right like our 14 year
olds or huh yeah so that's what we're
gonna talk about today we're gonna we're
gonna kind of zone this in focus it on
on parenting and I guess I have
self-serving reasons for that on some
level I mean we have a fourteen-year-old
daughter she just started a brand new
high school high school in general it's
her first year of high school but
instead of going to school near our
house she spent the majority of last
year putting together a portfolio a
visual art to try to get into the
performing arts high school here in Los
Angeles it's a public institution but
it's very prestigious very difficult to
get into you have to apply you have to
go and defend your portfolio it's a
whole thing
a lot of people are trying to get in and
she got in which is fantastic we
couldn't be happier or more proud of her
but this school happens to be a two-hour
drive from our house we live way out in
in Malibu Canyon near Calabasas this
school is east of downtown so for those
of you who know Los Angeles and think
about LA as just an octupus of freeways
I want you to even expand your concept
of that even further because to get from
where we live to this school which is is
on the 10 freeway after you pass
downtown on the way to like San
Bernardino it's just past downtown but
uh after you pass through the gridlock
exactly right when you get to the other
side of it and then you're there and
it's too far to do a daily commute I
mean you could you'll be in the car for
four hours every day it's not conducive
to - you know Mathis is development it's
certainly not advisable it's not
something I want to do or my wife wants
to do so we're trying to figure out she
just started two weeks ago we're trying
to figure out how are we gonna manage
this and create a sustainable solution
that works for not just Mathis but our
entire family and we've kind of settled
on the realization that there's no way
around the fact that we're gonna have to
rent an apartment near the school we
found a place that I think is probably
gonna work that's in downtown it's like
10 minutes from the school but this
means that we're appending our entire
family life my two older boys who are 22
and 23 moved out this past year so it's
just my wife and I on our two daughters
but we have a younger daughter who goes
to school right near our home so now
this is gonna mean that Julie and I are
gonna have to both be single parents
taking turns being downtown with our
older daughter while the other one is
tending to our younger daughter and then
switching so life is getting interesting
it's changing and what's beautiful about
it is that we are in this privileged
position to be able to support Mathis in
the furtherance of her dream because I
feel like
my family has done so much to support me
that allows me to do what I get to do
today and and it's her turn now and it's
a privilege as a parent to be able to be
able to show up for her in that way but
it's gonna be hard it's gonna be a lot
and and I and and also at 14 it's a very
interesting age you know where she's
trying to differentiate if it was up to
her she would just get an apartment by
herself and like manage it and she
doesn't need us she's already got the
whole world figured out and we're just
in her in her way and trying to figure
out how to parent through that in a
responsible way and you know be a voice
of reason for this developing young
adult is is a tricky equation to solve
well this is a beautiful picture because
you and Srimati you and your wife Julie
are I won't use the word resigning
because that's got a negative
connotation you're committing your lives
to the future and sustaining your lives
in the present at the same time imagine
if you were to be a normal whatever that
means
parent and you felt that this idea was
unreasonable that it was too much
disruption and then Malthus would grow
up with an unfulfilled dream and have to
live with that lack of that fulfilling
three four years of this incredible high
school for the rest of her entire life
which is you know what a hundred years
one hundred and ten hundred twenty years
whatever because we're in longevity over
50 years absolutely
well yeah so you're accommodating while
still sustaining you're accommodating
the future while sustaining
present what's more what's more
reasonable than that
right as well and it's crazy it is crazy
I would say we're attempting to
accommodate the situation it's uncertain
the sustainability aspect of it it is
unclear at this point and it is
unreasonable in many ways you can easily
make a logical argument as to why this
is totally unreasonable but that's why
it's so awesome because it is
unreasonable it's unreasonable for us to
say our daughter is going to go to the
school is two hours away that completely
disrupts our lives and makes it
challenging for Julie and I to even do
what we need to do professionally
throughout the day let alone attend to
our marriage
it's going to push us it's going to
challenge us but that's what makes it
super cool mm-hmm and I can't be
somebody who turns on a microphone and
sits here and tells people to pursue
their dreams if I'm not going to show up
for my daughter and do everything that's
in my power to to support her in the
furtherance of her own dream well let's
also think of that in terms of the
culture the culture and society of our
world right now in this modern version
is that it is so important for our
children to have the tools that they're
going to need to make this future
sustainable because science and
particularly deep science but even you
know even you know the layman's science
right now is talking about you know
humanity doesn't make it through to the
end of the century but then you have
people like you want to edit that out no
it's fine just keep rolling okay we're
good we heard an airplane yeah but then
you have you know this this idea of if
we keep producing children as we have
been we're gonna continue to make the
mistakes that we've been making mm-hmm
we start producing children
that are exceptional and extraordinary
because we supported them in their
dreams because these dreams are not
dreams that they've found in a magazine
somewhere these many instances these
dreams like Mathis your daughter these
dreams are these deep deep intuitive
dreams something that comes from way way
back in their evolution and if we can
allow those things to take place if we
can support those things in not only the
children that are biologically related
to us but in children in general and do
the things with the social structure do
the things with the cultures like
provide better education create these
schools create a school exactly like
that reproduce it out here closer to
home put five of them in every major
city some the deal with science some
that deal with technology some that deal
with the Arts some that deal with
athletics whatever it is and really
start addressing children not as all the
same but it's very unique individuals
yeah it would be beautiful if we could
accomplish that I mean I think that
you'd say to you a big drive time yeah I
know right if we could have this year
but but I feel like this particular
school is a good example of that because
every kid who's there had to apply and
had to jump through a lot of Hoops to
get there much like a child who's trying
to get into a college so every I said to
my daughter
you know a couple days into it I said
what's the biggest difference between
this school on the school you were going
to last year and she said everybody is
so happy to be there they all want to be
there Wow and isn't that a beautiful
thing like kids who are fourteen fifty
and all the way up to high school who
are there because that's where they want
to be not because that's where they're
told they have to be and the dropout
rate in today's world of education is is
understandable because the kids aren't
going to a school that serves their
passions
this school serves your daughter's
passion if we could enable schools to
serve passions and know that children
are being born on earth it happens
everywhere when your body is starting to
break down your body starts to produce
cells that are going to help it to save
it from breaking down further the same
thing is true in this world as this
world becomes less and less sustainable
the universe is providing children
through sole bodies and physical bodies
that are capable of turning this thing
around in other words the children that
are going to live deeply into the future
are capable of preparing us to sustain
the future and if we allow them to go
after their passions that's where the
message that they're trying to follow is
located so wow this is incredible but we
need to be very clear that the society
in general needs to be encouraged to
provide more of these kinds of
facilities right I feel like when this
young generation comes of age they're
they're they're capable of making that
change but I would like to see it a lot
sooner yeah you know we were talking a
little bit earlier off off the mics
about the Millennials and the
generations II and and how they they
really are qualitatively different from
my generation from your generation and
how they navigate and perceive the world
like this is a group of people that in
many ways gets a bad rap oh they're
entitled
oh they're you know they don't
understand this is the way it always is
right you know this is a sign that we're
just getting older but they get a bad
rap for being entitled babies or
whatever it is but ultimately you know I
have incredible relationships with young
people and it's one of the great things
about what I get to do is I get to be
around a lot of people who are much
younger than me and I see a group of hee
who are incredibly engaged to who who
are committed to working towards a
better future a better planet a better
country who truly believe that when they
spend their dollar that they are voting
for something they're either voting for
the world that they want to see or
they're voting against that like they
make that connection in a way that we
just never thought about really and that
gives me great hope and it makes me
optimistic for the future but I think we
have a lot of work in the meantime while
this while those generations are still
in gestation mode and we're still at the
hell mm-hm
I heard a comedian who was it the other
day tell a joke I can't remember who it
was but basically the joke went
something like you know when I pull out
in my car and I get behind a school bus
and all the kids in the back of the
school bus look out the back window and
give me the finger yeah why you give me
the finger I didn't do anything
and then I go oh yeah never mind yeah
created the world that they're saying
we're inheriting this world that you
have you know screwed up in so many ways
and now we gotta fix it for you yeah you
know that was actually Bill Maher what
it was Bill Maher yeah yeah is that that
monologue he does it yes and I just
heard that um what is it called rules
new rules yeah yeah so the idea that you
said you know we have to redefine terms
in many ways one of the terms that you
used was entitled and a lot of people
will use that word as a negative in a in
a derogatory statement but I look at it
as an opportunity an opportunity in an
opportunistic moment if a child is
entitled and they're not having to
struggle then they have the opportunity
to sit back and go okay what is it that
I'm actually motivated to do rather than
I don't have time to think about my vote
of motivation because I just have to
take care of what's going on and so
throughout history there's been this
constant struggle and all of a sudden
kids aren't struggling anymore they may
be struggling emotionally and we'll we
will deal without in a moment but and
they may be struggling in other ways but
there's a lot of there's a lot of things
out there that they're physically not
having to struggle with any longer which
gives them an opportunity to sit and
contemplate and when they sit and
contemplate sometimes you know when
they're sitting in daydreaming in school
that's a good opportunity for new ideas
to come through and they'll be
reprimanded for that I always remember
the old saying you know you spend the
first five years of your life learning
how to walk and talk and then go into
school and Barrett told to sit down and
shut up
right but the idea of being able to
daydream in a school and being able to
contemplate rather than always having to
look busy always having to look like
you're applying yourself at the same
time those moments of contemplation are
fewer and far between and are becoming
more and more compromised with the
encroachment of this little device we
carry around in our pockets that is
begging for our attention to instrument
right so the days of daydreaming under a
tree or you know kicking a can down the
road or going to build a dam in the in
the you know in the creek in the
backyard have all been supplanted with
technology and very addictive technology
at that so one of the things that I
struggle with and look you know I I'm
I'm as guilty of this as anybody but
it's particularly noticeable in in
younger people with minds that are still
in formation and still developing and
when you notice that the head you know
the neck is always craned and it's
facing the the device at all times it
leaves me to wonder where is that quiet
time where is that contemplation
happening where is that space that's
required for really trying to figure out
you know what your voice is and how to
express it I feel like that's really
being compromised in in a substantial
way well that is
an advice to parenting isn't it that you
do have to be able to enforce some
discipline I know now that I'm not
parenting I'm already done that my wife
and I have two children and now they
have children and so now we're
grandparenting and we're watching
parenting by Millennials you know and
we're watching the children that are
growing up under them and there's screen
time yeah and then there's not screen
time when they got back to from summer
vacation you know they had been in so
many locations where there were big
screens that the kids were just
basically you know where's the big
screen you know and so they took the TV
and they said it's out for repair and
they just removed the television and the
children now are getting into books and
things and they're getting back into
their routine and as soon as that
routine is reestablished they'll you
know reintroduce the screen but it's a
it's a challenge and it's a and it's a
challenge that parents must take on and
because to be fixated on that is a
couple of things physically it's too
much blue light in the system because
you know it's it's noontime Sun all day
all night which is disruptive to the to
the you know to the attitudes in the in
the psycho-emotional balance but it's
also very much involved in the moment in
a bad way
as opposed to being in the moment in a
good way in the now and the moment is
was I recognized in this moment did I
get a friend in this moment was I liked
in this moment that speech doesn't land
with the average 14 year old I'm not
talking to the fourth year you're
talking to the pair of the frightened
year-old
yeah because the moment can't compete
with the stimulus provided by the latest
post and a book
has a hard time standing up to the
allure of whatever's going on on YouTube
or Instagram it's hard and as a parent I
struggle with this and I struggle with
it personally I meant I'm as addicted as
anybody you know for the first to admit
that so finding a way to parent through
that is challenging because I I realize
like my job is not to be my children's
best friend it's to guide them and to
erect healthy boundaries and try to sort
of you know help them understand how to
develop in a healthy inappropriate way
but this is something I'm doing highly
and perfectly and and and I'm always you
know especially as my older daughter
gets older and she's like I said
differentiating she doesn't want to hear
about it
well I think that I think that what you
just said is very very important for
everyone to understand that we're going
to be experimenting at this these things
have only been around for a decade and
we will all be doing it imperfectly and
if we can't do things imperfectly
we will never find out how to do them
correctly because the learning curve in
anything that we do whether it's
training for a triathlon whether it's
working in meditation and yoga if we
don't allow ourselves to be imperfect
we'll never get good and I like the idea
of you know to equate this to another
part of what we talk about sometimes is
that going on a fast hmm going on a no
screentime going on an adventure just to
come back and have a different
relationship and a different perspective
of the screen and finding out that geez
you know I missed five days of of the
screen and you know I'm just as good as
I would have been otherwise I used to do
that with my guitar because as a matter
of fact I was going to bring my guitar
to me but
do it next time make sure got one right
behind me I should have had you play the
last okay ray that's good I can you sent
me that guitar Shirley Jolene and
Michael really know the people that
introduced us yeah
so if it's in tune I'll play it probably
not intent but you can so I used to go
on a guitar fast because I was obsessive
I was you know OCA
I caught it I never call it OCD I don't
consider it a disorder it's obsessive
compulsive advantage and I like that I'm
gonna use that yes I I encouraged it to
be used but I was Oca about playing my
guitar I was always if I had a moment I
would play my guitar if at a moment I
would play my guitar and then I realized
that my growth was very linear and was
very last moment based you know and good
linear growth this last moment based is
I'm learning this because I just learned
this so it's fulfilling the prerequisite
to something that you're going to
eventually learn and I saw that what was
happening if I went on these guitar
fasts which meant that I laid the guitar
aside went did other things for a week
or two weeks I once once went on a
guitar fast which is what my book buried
treasures for 11 months you know and my
style when I come back to the guitar
after these periods without it is not
based on what I've been doing it's based
on the imagination of what I could be
doing and all of a sudden I find after a
fast of such of a guitar playing that
all of a sudden my ideas are much
different and I'm trying to now develop
those ideas through practice so it's
really an accelerant same thing could
hold true for all of the social media
and how do I respond how do I experience
the likes and the dislikes the thumbs up
the thumbs down all these things about
all of these social media apps that are
on those devices being able to actually
get the child to understand a different
perspective a different relation in
their own not just trying to dictate
no time for that that's bad all the time
let's get our children to begin to
comprehend the difference between going
continuously and having breaks yeah it's
so important I mean removal altogether
is not the solution because this is the
this is the language with which they
communicate and being fluent in that
language I think is important for
success long-term I mean I just just
observation Lee watching young people
and the way they communicate it's
completely different to how we learned
how to communicate it's it's literally a
different language so I think
understanding that and respecting that
that's not going away is important but
it is so important to take those breaks
I think it's actually it's absolutely
critical and I think it's even more
crucial when you consider the fact that
you know a pre adolescent and adolescent
a teenager
these are developing brains and
emotional bodies who are trying to
figure out who they are how they fit in
the world I mean can you imagine being
that age and being assessed on an app
you could look at your phone and find
out what all your friends think about
you how you're you're being
qualitatively and quantitatively
evaluated throughout the day and if you
become ostracized you can use those apps
to then follow the people who have
ostracized you enjoying themselves in
your absence what is this what is the
impact of this on the psyche of a young
person it has the potential to be
unbelievably damaging and so outside of
just saying screen time no screen time I
think it's imperative for the parent to
shoulder the responsibility of
instilling a sense of self and a sense
of self confidence in their kids by
helping them develop sovereignty and a a
strong understanding of who they are
independent of the evaluation of their
peers hmm self evaluation really to
encourage self evaluation
you used another phrase a moment ago
that I have really relate to and that's
the the imperative that comes with
recognition with the recognition that
this is not going away I would equate it
back to 30 years ago when hip-hop was
just coming out and people just thought
okay it's gonna go away it's a fad and
all that but the thing about hip-hop was
that it was telling a story in a way
that stories had been told by indigenous
communities for a long time by poets for
a long time stories with rhythms stories
with beat now almost well not almost
everything now a lot of things are sold
commercially on media with hip hop beats
with hip hop structures attitudes the
dancing the ways and work it is not
going away nothing is going to go away
it's only going to increase and so if
parents recognize that these are things
that are it's really essential that you
begin to discipline them because they're
not not only not going away
but they're going to become more
powerful just like music becomes more
powerful over the decades these
apparatus are going to become not only
more powerful but more intimate I mean
now it's on a watch wait until it's
available in anything it's just a little
chip that you can attach anywhere yeah
it will be a chip implanted you know by
the time what my 14 year old is 40 you
know what is this going to look like
we're we're in this bizarre adolescent
phase with all of this where it's coming
at us so quickly we haven't really
adapted to it we don't really understand
the long-term impact of it and it's it's
it's being iterated upon with such an
accelerated pace that we can't keep up
with it and I think we're all just
stumbling very haphazardly and
imperfectly through our attempt to try
to understand and contextualize what
this all means I mean this is the
biggest advancement in human history
the fact that we have these these things
that that are really moving us towards a
collective consciousness where all of
our consciousness is merged
right now we're yelling at each other
and we're getting in arguments you know
okay but this is the this is the yeah
we're in the infant stage of trying to
figure out how we're how this
consciousness is all going to congeal
and coalesce in this cyber environment I
like what you just said in use the term
stumbling because in another session
that you and I shared we talked about
depression and grief and sadness we
talked about the difference between just
sort of being on the surface of it and
it's a continuous chronic condition and
then the people that were the SuperDuper
'z that are just living on the surface
of life and always just in the mask of
super how're you feeling great how you
doing super and this is the same
opportunity and that is that if we just
if we just are forced to ride the
surface of this event called social
media and devices and screens and all of
those things then we're never going to
get a good hold on it what we have to be
able to do as parents is we've got to be
able to dive down into this and really
understand what are the underpinnings
what are the causes why is my child or
my children or if I don't have children
why our children in general so obsessed
with this external valuation of their
latest moment and how can they be
inclined in a deeper dive to be
encouraged towards self evaluation and
you know just to heck with all of the
evaluation from the outside I can
remember as a young child and this was
back in the days when growing up as a
yogi you know in a judeo-christian
neighborhood you know I would get a lot
of flack because I was different you
know
my family was different everything was
different and and I was different and
one of the things that it gave me
because I was getting a lot of unlikes
if you were thinking about in my real
world unlike in the real world of social
media right in in the social structure
and I went to my mom one day and I was
crying I think I must have been like 6
or 7 and because we were Yogi's and
because we believed in you know in the
Church of all religions rather than just
being of a specific religion because
pada mahanta Yogananda was you know deep
in our families and our families by ohm
I came home and she said what's matter
I said everybody is saying I'm a heathen
right she said well do you know what
that means no but they they don't like
me because that's what I am right so it
was a big unlike right a big big
evaluation by my friends she said well
let's find out what that means right so
she she said go get the dictionary and
you know the families have the big
dictionary in those days and so I
brought the dictionary and we looked
under H E a right we looked under
heathen and she looked at and she read
it she said yeah you are
and now I want you to go out there and
be the best damn heathen that ever
existed excel as a heathen and show that
this word is not a condemnation it's
just a description and so I went back
out I got my basketball and I went back
out to the court and I was dribbling and
doing my shots and doing all the things
that I knew how to do very well and all
of a sudden people started to forget the
fact that they had gone through this
cycle and social media in today's world
is giving parents that same opportunity
but the parent as you said can't be
stumbling across the surface of this
dilemma they've got to be showing their
children that they're diving deep into
it even if they
stupid you know like a like a 50 year
old with teenage Jean jeans on you know
with big cuffs rolled up trying to look
cool know just be yourself and dive deep
into the dilemma and let's figure this
out together because it's on top of all
of us mm-hmm yeah I somebody who I
essentially make my living on the
Internet and I'm very versed in the art
and science of social media I'm an
omnipresent on many channels and have
been for a long time and and I think in
the in the realm of you know 50 plus
year old people I am much more fluent in
this language than most of my peers I
would say I feel like I have a better
grip on it grasp and understanding of
how it works and its importance and and
what's good and what's not so good about
it
so what's great about that is it allows
me to have a more productive
conversations with my kids about about
it but one of the things you said was
you know you know teenagers they're
they're obsessed with social media the
first thing I think that's important to
recognize is that if there is an
obsession that's that's in place it's
not the kids fault
these things are specifically designed
to create obsession to addictive Airi
powerful and potent like even the most
disciplined person has a challenge
trying to resist it's urgent its pull
there you go so first of all acknowledge
that yeah and I think if you can do that
then it will remove you from the
inclination to you know aggressively
come after your kid or shame them or say
like you got to get off that you're
obsessed you're addicted you know cuz
it's not it's not about that it's like
okay let's understand this you know how
can we create some healthy boundaries
around this to make it productive
understanding that this is how can you
communicate with your friends and this
is how you interface with the world and
that that indeed is not going to change
if anything it's going to increase but
to erect healthy boundaries so
you can carve out that contemplative
time so that you can craft a sense of
self and that you can cultivate enough
self-awareness to have a healthy sense
of yourself that is independent of how
many likes you get how many subscribers
do you have how many people are
following you know all of that nonsense
you used healthy boundaries and the fact
that you are very skilled in social
media you and your 50s and I and mine
that we have that skill in social media
makes us a better spokesperson for the
idea of healthy boundaries because we're
not a hypocrite saying something about
something we don't understand or
something that we don't participate in
we both participate fully in social
media and we both have to have that same
kind of discipline and so it gives us an
opportunity and I say to other parents
take the opportunity to begin to
understand what it is to instill
discipline in a child because if they're
just in the stimulus-response because
that's what social media is so good at
all you have to do is tap and click if
they're just in that stimulus and
response mode they're not going to get
ahead they're not going to fulfill their
destiny they're not going to fulfill
their passions and their and their
inclinations in life because they're
going to be trapped in the cycle so if
we can train them and say look at I'm
going to I'm in your game I'm in social
media
I'm also on these on these apps it's
part of my life it is my life it's my
world it's how I make my living but I'm
going to show you and we're going to
explore together what it's like to have
some abstinence what it's like to have
some discipline what it's like to get
sober right yeah to get sober on social
media to use it but not be used by it I
think that would be an important
expression yeah well I'm not idea of
using it versus being used by it there's
an important differentiator or
demarcation line that I don't think gets
adequately addressed or discussed which
is the distinction between
passively scrolling you know sort of
just checking out because your your your
your an audience member
versus creation if you're using YouTube
or Instagram or any of these other
platforms to express your creative voice
to share a point of view to make a video
to write a blog post to create to emote
to express yourself that's something to
be encouraged and that's very different
from just blindly like I'll check you
know I just I don't want to be with
myself and my emotions right now so I'm
just gonna see what everyone else is
doing and I think the more at least the
way that I've kind of approached this
with my kids is look I have no problem
with you being on these platforms if
you're out taking amazing photos and
editing them and have something
interesting to say and you're sharing
that
that's fantastic like I love that you
know let's do more of that and less of
the less of the absorption and more of
the creation good point because what we
have is we've got these different
sections just like times of day there's
a time to eat there's a time to digest
there's a time to rest there's a time to
be a bit passive there's a time to be
very active and we would not be
condemning I love your balance there we
would not be condemning any of these
properties if somebody just wants to
kind of you know scroll and be kind of
oblivious to the world and just see what
other people are doing that's an
opportunity to absorb some new ideas
perhaps or get some laughs out of some
some you know idiotic videos or jokes or
what-have-you but if that's a constant
diet then that's a something that needs
to be repaired and replaced yeah I'd
agree with that but it can be a part of
the overall structure so you know
scrolling through see what other people
are doing what's what's happening out
there having time to be without the
device to be able to get new ideas that
have nothing to do with the devices
another part of your day and
other party or day be actively taking
this creating that thinking this posting
that it's another part of the day
literally being a fully a verbs a fully
active member of this internet society
contributing in many ways and allowing
it to contribute to you in many ways and
as a parent having what you said before
you're not just a good buddy
but you're also a guide you have to also
be a good buddy at times and especially
as your children get you know to be like
the know-it-all fourteen you know that
that we all experience and we've all
experienced when you've had children
we've got to be able to know what is
that spectrum of relationship there's
got to be it's almost like a recipe
there's got to be some good buddy
there's got to be some guide and there's
got to be some just co-relation just a
just a sense of the self with another
self mm-hmm yeah I'm trying to figure
out how all those pieces fit together is
that is your in the middle of it and I'm
observing it from having been through it
yeah I you know I would say with respect
to my daughter you know I'd said earlier
she's ready she's you know doesn't want
to have it that she you know she's she's
ready to move out and all of that and I
say that a Jess but at the same time
like what I am most proud of with her is
that she does have a very strong sense
of herself she's very self-sufficient
she knows what she wants she doesn't
equivocal equivocate in her language
like she's very direct she's very
unapologetic for who she is like these
are all amazing qualities of a very
strong person which are fantastic but
she still is just 14 so you gotta like
you know definitely guide that person
and that's kind of where I'm at right
now
but I want to get back to that idea of
taking an intermittent fast and you'd
use the example of taking a break from
guitar that allowed you to go from a
place of linear progression to one of
like quantum progression
and I think that's really weird powerful
I was listening to a podcast by my
friend Rob Bell do you know Rob Bell
I've heard the name he's a really cool
interesting thinker and he he calls this
idea of the what you're kind of coining
a fast as Manu ha which is a word from
Scripture that I can't remember what he
said in his podcast how it where it
exactly derives from but essentially
this idea
Manu ha meeting the importance of of
rest you know if I'm taking a break and
reframing how we think about this as
sort of indulgent or lazy and
understanding that it's perhaps the the
most powerful you know Archimedes lever
that you have that it is the white space
being between space that defines the
hard lines beautiful and without that
break without that respite without that
fast or rest you are preventing yourself
from ultimately developing to your
potential as a voice as a creative and
whatever it is that you're seeking to
seeking to express well that brings up
in my psyche the maneja is at it the new
Han Anu ha
Manu ha is the maneja of parenting what
if you were to as a parent out there
what if you were to set up a time where
you actually just take a break and it
would have to be on your own time and in
your own schedule but you take a break
from being a parent take a break from
being the person who has to know what to
do take a break from the person that has
the answers and just come up with the
idea that you don't know what the heck
you're doing and you have no answers in
this moment and see what can fill that
space that empty space you taught you
talked about the white space or though
what was it the Michaela white space see
what fills that empty space
and allow yourself to come up with ideas
that you never thought of before by
taking that fast from parenting like
fast from guitar fast from this fast
from that and allowing just like when
you take a fast the body restores it it
says wow I'm sure sure glad we don't
have to digest food today because now we
can do all those repair jobs that we've
been putting off because we've been
spending all of our energy and digestion
and now we can take some work to do some
the needed tasks and all of a sudden if
you take a break and fast from being the
parent being the one who knows
everything and suddenly just say you
know what at this point in my child's
development I need to learn I need to be
a student uh-huh I need to listen yeah I
think that's important I I you know I
don't have a problem telling my kids I
don't know I think if they say you know
what they ask a question unusual in that
way yeah I mean I think that's a it's a
you know it's something the generation
that preceded me wouldn't have ever
thought of like because you're you're
trained to always have the answer and
and and part of that comes I think from
a lot of all instinct of protectionism
like you want to protect your kids so
you're you want to make them feel safe
and secure so you're the person who
always knows the answer to the questions
safe and secure fulfilled yeah but I'll
be like I don't know I'm gonna have to
get back to you on that one you know and
I think and I think I think the one of
the reasons that I think that's that's
beneficial is it breeds trust in your
child like I think you know kids are
much more intuitive than we give them
credit for and if your biessing them
with some answer and they they they know
that you don't really know they see
through that thing and I think they
appreciate the honesty and I think
ultimately they're more likely to trust
you if you know you're you you cop to
the occasional I don't know or you screw
up and you say hey you know what I just
really handle that situation poorly you
know yeah I was what i tried to do
here's where I screwed up and I'm gonna
do better next on
I was yeah I do that now in and it's
very rewarding
I was our children both live in Pacific
Northwest and as do our grandchildren
and I was we were up there the other day
and I was checking in with him I said
you know I just wanted to I just wanted
to know what did I look like and I
didn't mean what did I physically look
like but what did i parentally look like
at different sections of your life I
mean what's the earliest memory that you
have of me and I think both them said
you're really strict and and then you
got to be okay with certain things and I
was thinking okay so that's their view
of who I was I would have been much
wealthier not in not in money but in
experience if I'd have been asking them
that along the way mm-hmm and so I would
HIGHLY encourage you know parents out
there to get into that stance that I can
tell you do a lot but you know just to
be able to sit down there as if you're
one of them get on the same side of this
and I don't mean the physical screen but
get on the same side of the relational
screen and say you know what do I look
like up there on that screen in other
words like a performance review alright
we're gonna sit down yes yes because
they have an insight that nobody else
does they don't always have to be an
audience member they could be a critic
it must have been tricky raising your
kids yeah and everything like that like
I can't imagine that was that was
without it's traumas and challenges
right and I would say if I had it all to
do over again the knots would have been
tied much looser because like I was
saying earlier the children have an
inborn knowledge they have an inborn
wisdom because they are the ones that
are gonna have to live with the future
much further out too
we will and we've got to hear from that
more thank God I was a musician and and
had a lot of you know I had a lot of
relationships in which you had to be a
band member rather than a you know a
lead singer all the time and in that
metaphor you have to be able to play off
of other people so you know once the you
know once the complete you know I don't
know what I'm doing so I better show
that I do know what I'm doing god I got
over that phase then I started
co-relating with my with our children so
that we could be more of a team rather
than just a you know a coach you know
telling the players what to do
yeah one of the struggles that I have
the challenges that I have and I think
this is relatable for you know anyone
who's listening or watching is I
struggle to not project some past
experience of my own or some past trauma
on to my kids in other words it's very
difficult to have the wherewithal or
awareness to step outside whatever cycle
or pattern you've habituated yourself to
because of the way that you were raised
and then repeat that pattern with
respect to how you're parenting your
kids because that's just what you know
even if you're trying to do things
differently I found that all
automatically default to something that
you know some scenario that you know
just the way that I was raised that I
was trying to do we do a little bit
differently and ijen so you know we're
not having awareness of that is one
thing but it's a very different thing to
prevent myself from falling into that
trap or perpetuating that habit and I
say that that's what these fasts maneja
my new ha could can give us that in
playing the guitar when I wasn't playing
the guitar obsessively I would discover
ways that were not things that I had
learned in my past you used a beautiful
phrase you said you know you you quantum
you use the quantum effect of of the
Manu ha of the fast I know you love that
word I do see what am i passionate
but the fact is is that yes we could we
can do the same thing in those pause
moments where we're not saying that we
know everything let me just say that I
know nothing and I I'm in a situation
you know it's almost like a moment of
Prayer you know like the the the prayer
that's being used in in recovery you
know God give me the grace got me the
strength I mean you know the courage etc
that show me the way you know show me
the way through this let me learn some
new let me learn some new chords let me
learn some new riffs let me learn some
new ways of addressing my children
because I wasn't schooled no one was
this is not a statement just of me
personally but no one was the one thing
that we didn't get in high school in
college was parenting 101 parenting 102
parenting 103 we never got even
relationship we got you know the 3 R's
but we certainly didn't get all of these
other things we got psych you know
psychology 101 within sociology but
that's how to look at the thing hmm how
do we get how to be the thing yeah we're
not taught we know the way we were
raised what you what I see a lot of is
people who are raised a certain way and
then suddenly their parents and they're
like I'm gonna do it totally the
opposite because of whatever trauma they
suffered so they'll swing swing that
pendulum all the way in the other
direction and then of course that's
always wrong with its own it's fraught
with all its its own you know issues and
problems but I think that's beautiful is
evidence there's an old saying that
wisdom use pendulum there's an old
saying of wisdom that when is the
pendulum at its best when it's still
it's still in the middle yeah it's never
it's never still
although you know that's a thing there
wouldn't be a pendulum then a just
dangling yeah but that is the case what
you talk about in that pause in that
fast in that period of time of the white
space of being able to bring in so point
is encouraging not only parents but also
children to respect the white space yeah
and to respect the time when let's all
just kind of be here not in our roles
but let's just take a break from our
roles for this moment and let's try to
be in this place of being able to accept
each other with our flaws and our and
our talents good example our one of our
children was seven years old teacher
Cotter not being able to read yet she
had been perfectly faking it
teachers come to me and my wife they say
we'd like to get her some serious
tutoring and I think about it and I
think about my daughter's incredible
skills she had huge athletic skills she
had huge musical skills she had
incredible skills of communication but
she had not latched onto this one skill
of being able to read yet and I said
well that's okay but I said I don't want
you to disrupt that you know to improve
this skill but I don't want you to
disrupt these other skills by inserting
something that's you know magnificent
and but making it more important than
the other skills that she does have or
making her feel any kind of shame or any
kind of thing and they looked at me and
how strongly I was feeling and they said
well maybe we should just let you work
with this and we'll see how we how we
can progress so I sat with it and I went
into this space and I sat with with our
daughter and I went into this space
of I'm not the dad I'm a mirror let me
hear what's going on and so she and I
just kind of hung out for a little while
for quite a while and in the process I
recognized and she recognized cuz she
kind of brought it out to me that she
had sort of missed catching on until she
was so far behind that she was afraid to
admit that she hadn't caught on yeah
that's what happens and so I said oh wow
I said well let's let's show that being
behind and making mistakes is just as
valuable as being ahead and getting it
right and so with the four of us our two
children and my wife and I spent a
weekend doing things wrong we went to
the probably the only still existing
bowling alley in the area and we had to
throw gutter balls but we had to win the
game we had to see who could get the
ball the furthest down the alley before
it went into the gutter uh-huh and so
and the winner of the game had to have
zeroes all across the board by the end
of the game but have gotten it as far
down the alley
well eventually that we were laughing so
hard that they kicked us out so we went
to a public swimming pool that still had
a diving board and we had to do belly
flops and we had to see how high we
could go before the sting of the belly
flop was prohibitive so we had to do all
these things wrong and we were
hilariously laughing and then we started
to spell words wrong you know we started
to spell words phonetically like enough
en you F and rather than en ough right
and we started to realize how much of
the that you should be able to or you
should be doing
we're completely controlling the mindset
she ended up you know being on a Dean's
List being you know head of her class
she graduated topper you know because
she realized making mistakes was okay
education needs to honor the mistakes
and you were talking before we try to
protect our children we try to help them
get there get things right we try to do
all these things well we may be
partially contributing to contributing
to the dilemma what I read into that is
that the crisis if you want to call it a
crisis that's not really the right words
a little too severe but the the sort of
problem that needed to be addressed was
less about the fact that she couldn't
read that's easily rectified through
some pretty you know simple basic you
know tutoring the real issue was her
fear of speaking up in the wake of
getting passed by hmm and the redress of
that is to reframe this whole idea of
failure doing things wrong by making it
fun and and this is something I talk
about all the time like I wish the word
failure didn't exist there should be a
different word a more permissive word
that makes people feel encouraged by
trying things even if they're not gonna
work out but it's that fear you know and
with that fear is like the shameless
shameless I'm behind you know these kids
are ahead of me I can't speak up because
I don't be judged and getting out ahead
of that is ultimately much more
important than just dealing with the
reading part of it think of it in
parenting parents I mean there's an
there's there's a there's a metric for
when you can't read but there's no
metric for when you don't know how to
parent in this moment and to be able to
fail from time to time in parenting and
admit it is in the same category
we need to be able to say hey I need
help here we need to be able to go to
the child and say hey I need your help
here you're doing this I see an end
result that vision of your end result
maybe from my past help me show me that
you've thought this through that you
don't see that same end result that if
you do see an end result let's compare
our views of the end results of your
behavior having that kind of a
relationship with a child is after a lot
of failing in my world that's what I
ultimately have with my children now you
know you know one of them's 40 and the
other ones 30 right it's easier to have
that conversation now yeah right but I'm
encouraging people to have that
conversation much earlier yeah and and
what I read into that is is a respect
for their own sovereignty like hey it's
not me telling you what to do great like
we're in some kind of partnership here
where I'm still in charge you know but
like let's have some productive feedback
let's make it a two-way street how are
you am i projecting this onto you or are
you seeing this the same way you know I
think that's that's interesting because
that would start a conversation that
demonstrates a willingness and will and
willingness are part of the heart center
you know it's part of that vulnerability
that you and I have spoken about from
time to time the vulnerability of being
I don't have the answers I don't have I
have some answers they may not apply
here right and I think the fear is
apparent is that the kid you think the
kids gonna go man they're just asleep at
the wheel like this thing's out of
control is I got to take control of this
situation you know the exact opposite
ultimately if you give the child a sense
of parents were never trained to be that
children were never trained to be
children let's do this together
yes I do have you know it's like an
18-wheeler has a better view than a
Porsche down the roadway
I do have the altitude that gives me a
better view of the roadway but some of
my view of the roadway is in using your
terms maybe based on my history maybe
based on the way I was parented may not
be based on your roadway so let's get
together in this dialogue in this
communication I remember one time I was
having a conversation with one of our
children and in the midst of the
conversation the child goes papa
timeout I've been listening really is it
like ten minutes in I've been listening
really carefully they were very
respectful I've been hearing every word
you've said what's your point
yeah what is your point that moment
changed my world because I realized that
not only in that parenting role but also
in my teaching role that I would come
into a class with so many perspectives
and so many points that I was so
enthusiastic and inspired about getting
across that it was just way too much
information yeah your job as a
communicator
she's saying be you're not communicating
very well yes so in your experience as a
parent and now as a grandparent like if
you had to distill down to a couple
nuggets what are the most important
things for a parent to bear in mind in
raising a conscious child in a healthy
way that we haven't already covered I
mean we're talking about this stuff yeah
be flexible in positioning number one
don't always be the authority be
flexible in the positioning number two
gain perspective from your audience
every product that's ever been sold
successfully has had consumer feedback
so let's just put it in
that role that your child is your
audience your child is your customer
you're trying to sell yourself as a
parent you're trying to sell them on
your ideas get some feedback maybe your
guidance is great except for and you
will find where the exceptions are and
number three be in what you've said
you're able to do a lot of and that is
admit to the fact that you there is no
training
there's only experience that's then
applied to a new experience of the
experience of a child being parented by
a parent gets implied by the parent
that's parenting a child and those
things don't always have a growth
perspective they sometimes they're not
necessarily evolving sometimes they're
devolving yeah because I think what
happens and something I've had to be
very attuned to is the fact that that
that I or we as parent and we all have
our woundings and our you know our our
triggers and if our child says something
that that pushes one of those buttons
that's been within us you know that was
installed 50 years ago 40 years ago
you're gonna react in some old unhealthy
pattern and you're not even consciously
aware of what you're doing it's in the
zone yeah it's like and that perpetuates
some unhealthy pattern that you know
that comes from who knows where
right but developing the the awareness
to understand that these there are
patterns that are in place like we all
have these grooves and it's easy to stay
in a groove and it's hard to get out of
that groove we all have past traumas and
woundings and these are easily triggered
and and produce results that are that
are reactive that don't come with
conscious thought and awareness that
aren't that aren't consciously thought
through and without developing some
awareness and some
prophylactic prophylactic behavior
patterns to kind of insulate yourself
against falling into those traps you are
gonna perpetuate you know some old
pattern that you're that you're so
desperately trying to to you know
transcend and overcome as the child
gives you feedback because the child is
always giving feedback that's one of the
things that because I work with a lot of
people you know teenagers 20s 30s 40s
50s 60s the ones that are the most
perhaps the most honest because they
haven't been trained in the dishonesty
of masking as much are the ones that are
in the teenage the adolescent category
and I find that the feedback loop from
them can be very you know very chaotic
and and sometimes hurtful because they
haven't masked it they haven't they
haven't polished it and so rather than
correcting the way in which the feedback
is coming I would let I would advise
parents to you know take that feedback
and take it into a white space a
personal white space where you kind of
like extract the messaging from it just
like I had to with our our daughter and
I had to another time with our son is
extract the messaging from their
description of what they were
experiencing and in doing so I won't
have to have the answer now I can also
say to them let me get back to you which
is something that buys you the white
space buys you that that pause that fast
that would be an important component
also that would be a fourth advice that
I would give is you know by the space
that gives you time to be able to have
more of a contemplative relationship
with the information that sometimes
being dealt to you in a very
disrespectful or seemingly disrespectful
way really what it is it's just very
emotional very artists very overwhelmed
it's usually very it's direct yeah it's
honest generally yes yeah and maybe they
are like your daughter Mathis absolutely
certain that they know everything that
they need to know and then you're saying
what you said to me earlier off-mike she
doesn't know what she doesn't know and
so it's up to us to then sort of like be
a hover rat you know kind of a
hovercraft not in an obsessive way but
to be able to give the child that
because sometimes they come off with
this within a very kind of like
aggressive languaging but give the child
the ability to follow that trajectory
and just be there in case it sort of
runs off the rail
yeah just nudge it here and there and I
think that goes back to the sovereignty
peace my salient word again because I
love that was use it in so many ways but
sovereignty of a child god bless you for
you I mean the more sense of sovereignty
that a developing you know adolescent
has or child I think that that
contributes to cultivating that sense of
self that that that we all want kids
mm-hmm and that's coming from me who is
no expert and not doing anything and
that is going to all of us who are no
expert you know I would say that there
in the raising of children there is no
expert but there are those who are more
open who are more vulnerable who will
allow more sovereignty they'll be more
skilled but nobody's expert manu ha my
friend I think we did it
blessings how do you feel I feel great
feel good yeah I do all right
will you come back and share more with
me man this is a joy right on right on
cool oh you know what grab that guitar
behind let's see if it's - yeah I did
I'm sure it's not no one's picked it up
in a little while
but you could always attuned let's see
if we could do you know I like that mic
up to that
[Music]
[Applause]
so this is Axios
[Music]
this is a song that seal and I recorded
together
I was actually Anna it was written by
myself and a bunch of kids in India
years and years ago but it was to me to
be confident that the infinite will take
care of it we is so fortunate oh and to
be confident that the infinite and the
kids would all start singing it to be
confident that the internet will take
care of it who is so fortunate all to be
confident that the infinite
[Music]
we'll take care of it we're so fortunate
and that in parenting is extremely
important to know that there's some
force greater than us that is taking
care of and trusting that we can take
care of these children that is so
important for us to remember that we are
being entrusted we're not being hired
we're being entrusted not because we're
experts
but because we're foolish enough to be
willing enough to be co-relating enough
and coordinating enough beautifully put
my friend love you much love love you
love you too and love to all of those
that put up with us for this time very
good man until next time peace peace
plan it's forever all right
[Music]
you